I had a black dog.
His name was Depression.
Whenever the black dog made an appearance,...
...I felt empty and life just seemed to slow down.
He would surprise me with a visit for no reason or occasion.
The black dog made me look and feel older than my years.
When the rest of the world seemed to be enjoying life,...
...I could only see it through the black dog.
Activities that usually brought me pleasure suddenly ceased to.
He liked to ruin my appetite.
He chewed up my memory and my ability to concentrate.
Doing anything or going anywhere with the black dog required superhuman strength.
At social occasions, he'd sniff out what confidence I had and chase it away.
My biggest fear was being found out.
I worried that people would judge me.
Because of the shame and stigma of the black dog,...
...I was constantly worried that I'd be found out,...
...so I invested vast amounts of energy into covering him up.
Keeping up an emotional lie is exhausting.
Black dog could make me think and say negative things.
He could make me irritable and difficult to be around.
He would take my love and bury my intimacy.
Eventually, I felt totally isolated from everything and everyone.
The black dog had finally succeeded in hijacking my life.
When you lose all joy in life, you can begin to question what the point of it is.